l'immunité collective professeur sans
doute pour vacciner les enfants on peut
estimer qu'il faudrait que 75% de la
population née 67 millions de français
soit de protéger soit par la vaccination
soit par l'infection naturelle
si on ne cherche à vacciner que les
adultes on aura du mal à y arriver même
si tout le monde y met du sien donc
probablement il faut qu'une fraction des
enfants lors peut-être donc la réponse
est oui
peut-être qu'il suffirait j'en sais rien
de vacciner mettons les plus de 10 ans
pas les petits poulets plus de cinq ans
j'en sais rien mais peut-être pas tous
les ans mais les surveiller fois qu'il
vacciner les enfants aujourd'hui d'avoir
votre avis moi j'ai ma petite idée aussi
l'atuge jimmy mohamed mon ami mon frère
mon tout est avec nous remercie mon ami
médecin bien entendu qu'on retrouve sur
europe 1 et qu'on va retrouver longtemps
par tous parce qu'il est excellent merci
mon dieu il est là et florian philippot
merci d'être là également président du
parti
les patriotes qui commence sur la
vaccination des enfants merci d'être là
merci à vous deux jimmy t pour la
vaccination des enfants
bah en fait quand on parle la
vaccination des enfants on parle aussi
les vaccinations des plus jeunes
on peut se demander pourquoi est-ce
qu'on vaccine ray un enfant de 12 14 15
16 ans ou même un jeune homme de 20 ans
puisque finalement on nous dit que les
formes graves de coronavirus et les
personnes âgées et c'est vrai néanmoins
il faut pas oublier que on aura malgré
tout en laissant circuler le virus des
jeunes et des enfants qui feront des
formes graves et certains vont en mourir
même si ses minoritaires mais je pense
que c'est un mort de trop même si
finalement heureusement ça restera un
papa pas la règle n'oubliez pas que
lorsqu'on laisse circuler le virus on
s'expose à ce qu'on a pu voir dans
certains pays aux variants c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on aura accès par exemple 80%
la population si on laisse le virus
circule et chez les plus jeunes
eh bien le virus il va essayer de muter
il va essayer de résister à la
vaccination et tôt ou tard on s'expose
invariants qui sera peut-être plus grave
chez les enfants plus grave chez les
jeunes et qui ne répondra pas à la
vaccination et finalement on va
recommencer comme avant avec du
confinement des morts et la galère et
puis mine de rien il ne faut pas oublier
une dernière chose et c'est un des
éléments importants pour que les jeunes
comprennent aussi qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent vacciner lorsque vous avez 20
ans si vous faites vacciner vous allez
avoir un bon système immunitaire et vous
allez éviter de transmettre la maladie
aux autres et en particulier aux
personnes âgées plus fragiles dont on
sait que la vaccination marche un peu
moins quand vous avez 80 ans voici ces
militaires est moins performante
regardez ces deux là non mais le
réalisateur montre et jean bernard
isabelle morini-bosc ordonné s'est
améliorée d'autres c'est un autre sens
bien je sais pas il souhaitait les
choses et elle s'est donc essayé mais je
pense qu'elles peuvent accéder les
autres finalement les plus jeunes
sauteurs lorsqu'ils verront à pied ou ma
mission maintien buzz
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
florian et donc les jeunes finiront par
probablement contaminé les personnes
âgées dont on sait ça que la réponse
immunitaire elle va pas durer
éternellement
et donc pour qu'on soit tous en sécurité
eh bien il faudra certainement vacciner
les enfants mais encore une fois le tout
c'est pas de donner une injonction
fini le temps où les médecins devraient
dire doivent dire fethi fait ça il faut
expliquer qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
vaccin
quels sont les risques quels sont les
bénéfices et après libre à vous de
décider mais je pense que vu la période
qu'on a connu et bien il faudra que les
jeunes et les plus jeunes s'attaquent ce
n'est qu'au musée le professeur fisher
on parle pas d'enfant de un ou deux ans
certainement
chez ceux qui chez qui le virus circule
beaucoup les enfants partir de 10 ans et
on a bien vu que la fermeture des écoles
et associer systématiquement une baisse
de l'épidémie donc à l'avenir c'est une
façon de sécuriser un peu les écoles et
nos sociétés dur a dit vous êtes contre
non je suis content enfin cela dit jean
et m'a convaincu donc évidemment je suis
pour maintenant je veux dire c'est que
moi ma fille par exemple elle a dit elle
va avoir 18 ans et moi j'ai très envie
qu'elles soient vaccinées parce que je
considère que ma fille elle elle est à
gros risques parce que elle elle va
sortir
elle va voir des amis elles valent en
boîte de nuit est là elle va aller dans
les bars elle est plus dangereuse que
maurice est par exemple dans un ehpad
mais non mais c'est pas la priorité pour
moi ça va pas trop donc des temps je
pense que c'est on y viendra mais moi je
ne serais tu étais plutôt laid et 20 30
ans et oui les avants tu vois 12 ans
apparaissait un peu jaloux et florian
philippot ben non vous savez combien il
ya de morts de bucovine en france chez
les 0 20 ans depuis quinze mois une à 15
sur plus de 15 millions certains de 15
millions d'habitants et les airs ou 30
ans même y en a 90 met donc en réalité
la balance puisque on parle quand on est
en vacances enfin le balance bénéfice
risque
elle serait en désaveu alors mais les
drivers de la vaccination chez les
enfants et chez les jeunes ceux qui sont
favorables à la vaccination chez les
jeunes c'est surtout pour la
transmission alors j'allais y venir donc
d'abord un problème soulevé de fond la
balance n'est pas bonne pour les enfants
et pour les jeunes et ça c'est quand
même un élan de problèmes à la basse
deuxième problème la transmission je
vois ce en quoi vous fondez là dessus
parce que la cilicie américaine qui est
l' agence des maladies américaine sur
son site internet
elle écrit en ce moment certains
éléments sur la transmission l'arrêt de
la transmission quand on est vacciné je
dois lancer c'était au mois de mars une
étude d'au moins six mois ça nous
conduirait en septembre prochain
pour le savoir vous n'avez pas
d'éléments sérieux on retire le masque
aux états unis
ça veut bien dire que la vaccination
efficace le masque et objets religieux
qu'on retire ou qu'on retire pas et ça
ne coûte rien à voir avec la vaccination
jeunes à s'y méprendre exemple prendre
l'exemple du texas a retiré début mars
il y avait 9 % de vacciner à l'époque
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui l'épidémie est en
très forte baisse alors quelques 30 % y
s'a servir tout le temps mais parce que
je souffre d'un autre exemple le
portugal
ils ont un à deux morts y aura toujours
un sauté sur le port très chaud le
portugal 1-2 manque l'argent depuis des
semaines
pourtant ils ont même taux de
vaccination legend ya quelques mois
alors que c'était un modèle
extraordinaire
l'un vous savez bien c'est une
catholique en inde il ya dix fois moins
de morts parmis tant qu en france et dix
fois moins un mois dans les opéras
milliard 400 millions d'habitants la
transmission je vous signale que quand
un vieil homme de 83 ans doublement
vacciner a saisi le conseil d'état il ya
un mois en disant moi je suis là qu
signer donc je vais pouvoir être des
confits n'est pas ce que tu vas vers en
mini de la santé un solide et olivier m
a dit au conseil d'état non ne le
déconfit n'est pas parce que nous
n'avons pas d'éléments sur la non
transmission ça c'est vrai on est
vacciné arrêté il ya deux mois tous à
l'énorme attente agences et les volumes
journée avait jours et désormais on sait
qu'il n'ya pas de risque de vous n'avez
pas d'évolution des choses que la
cilicie en train de travailler là-dessus
et par ailleurs même quand même 6 à
empêcher la transmission très bien mais
alors on transmet pas à des gens qui
sont vaccinées or vous semblez croire
totalement à la vaccination donc où est
le problème
ou alors vous transmettez à des gens qui
ne sont pas vaccinés mais c'est de leur
propre chef
donc en fait on utiliserait les enfants
achètent comme une sorte de bouche-trou
bouche seringue ont les vaccinés ray de
force alors que eux n'ont aucun risque
aucun risque de mourir de faim de faire
une forme de graphe du coville ou harris
infinitésimale par contre ils ont des
risques d'effets secondaires pour
pallier le la volonté des autres même si
ça n'a pas de sens si un fan
philosophique et très résolument razzano
dans clip autant un énorme risque de
transmission monsieur philippe aux
menaces actuelles des écoles ferment là
on a réouvert ya des écoles qui commence
déjà à faire mais combien agréable mais
pas réguler la transe que les si on est
dans le sens d' absurde qu'on la vérité
leur auto parce qu'on a des raisons d'y
proposer rien toute façon opposé jamais
rien mais moi je propose une chose c'est
qu'on arrête de fermer des lits à
l'hôpital c'est qu'on s'intéresse au
traitement précoce pour éviter la
capitalisation
et ça je sais que c'est un sujet qui
n'intéresse pas industrie
n'importe pas rond les je demande qu'on
s'intéresse aux personnes vulnérables
celles qui meurent du coc vide pas qu'on
mette sous cloche
une société ce qui a des impacts et moi
je me bats contre ça et limites
écologiques ça vous ne tenez pas compte
non plus vous regardez % pour l'immunité
collective n'a rien à [ __ ]
non mais regardez la réalité par
l'histoire la réalité c'est quand je
reviens au texas il ya deux mois et demi
le texte il ya deux kilomètres et demi a
oui mais ça c'est pas ça vous gêne et le
texas et ça me gêne mais c'est pas ce
que voulait pas que j'en parle c'est le
deuxième état le plus peuplé vitesse il
ya 29 millions d'avis alors on peut
parler du texas et ben oui début mars il
dit dans le groupe début mars on ouvre
tout cas pas de jauge ya plus de masque
obligatoire
il ya le pass ait avec roy interdit au
texas et bien aujourd'hui ils ont fait
des matchs de baseball 40000 spectateurs
dans le snat uss cole et sans masque
aujourd'hui l'épidémie tanche était
pourtant à l'époque des gens comme vous
et joe biden et tout avait si ça va mais
prenez moi l'exemple d'israël qui est un
super laboratoire oui mais alors le
polygone et moi ils ont cependant
lorsque adéquat vous dit zéro mort c'est
du faux vaccins alors que texas a causé
aux morts c'est pas non c'est parce que
votre premier moindre à lille à 10 km
dans sa voiture ouais j'suis bien alors
lisez aussi manger de te dire combien
peut pas faire l'émission la guerre des
voisins un texte compliqué en fait vous
faites parfois la corrélation avec la
vaccination quand ça vous arrange
parfois vous ne la fera quand ça vous
arrange les fusibles et portes du galet
texas
deuxièmement moi je suis désolé il faut
dire faut appeler un chat un chat il ya
une industrie pharmaceutique qui veut
faire du fric dans cette affaire qui ont
fait déjà beaucoup
c'est ce qu'il veut la valeur avant
connaissait pas le monde arabe
laboratoire maintenant c'est devenu
s'est passé il nous tympanise maintenant
je peux citer plein de laboratoire
bientôt je vais mettre dans un
baccalauréat
suite au nombre de bateaux est celle que
vous avez oxfam la loi angie qui dit ce
matin 9 milliards d'heures
supplémentaires liés à la vaccination
covit pour 19 milliards de dollars et
quelques notes ça c'est une réalité
deuxième un deuxième problème éthique
moi je suis désolé on en train de faire
une pression sur nos jeunes pour qu'ils
la piscine
vous avez vu le maire de new york qui
dit si vous vacciner vous avez un burger
frites tu déjà vu ça c'est l'heure on a
offert des glaces aussi en russie est
d'accord
vous savez qu'en plus c'est complètement
problématique parce que l'obésité est un
des problèmes est un des facteurs de
comorbidité du coc vide ça donc c'est
pas hyper quand même le niveau c'est
quand même un acte médical de faire
vacciner c'est pas comme ça vous pourrez
demain voyager prendre l'avion et là
aussi on allait signer ou non ça va
changer depuis alain foix n'a toujours
pas vexé ni non vous faire la vie active
il n'y aurait pas vous faire vacciner
ben je pense pas je pense pas et
principe de précaution
aujourd'hui on continue à vacciner des
enfants va bien vous faire dès la
version reçoit un traitement
ok moi je suis d'accord à part la guerre
aujourd'hui moi je suis arrivé à tout le
monde la vaccination les enfants déjà la
mortalité ça ne les concerne pas ou peu
la transmission c'est pas très claires
et pardon moi je trouve qu'on n'a pas
assez de recul sur ce vaccin
imaginez dans 10 ou 20 ans on se rend
compte que c'est dangereux et qu'on
aimait vacciner des milliers des
millions d'enfants pour rien qu'en soit
jusqu'à 10 la siba c'est vrai on n'a pas
de recul sur ce vaccin c'est vrai et
c'est vrai que ça marche un vaccin est
reine en guinée blanc
si on m'avait nommée tout le monde nous
parle d'un danger mais comment ça marche
un vaccin est reine est ce que vous
aimez que l'on peut expliquer simplement
jamais cessé qu'avec ça résume ce que
j'ai fait un petit peu peur board pour
un petit système qui schéma rapidement
là c'est le texas ali mohammed vous
n'etes et un schéma pour qu'on comprenne
ce qu'est exactement où et laisser le
texas c'est l'accord amendé but alors on
part alors assez c'est un bon départ
dans des buts alors là pour faire très
simple vous avez un coronado coronavirus
on sait c'est un virus à arn qui va être
juste là le coronavirus là une
particularité c'est qu'ici il a une
protéine qu'on appelle la protéine
spikes et la protéine c'est d'ailleurs
cette protéine qui va s'accrocher sur la
cellules pulmonaires et vous rendre
malade
ah merde ce qu'on a réussi à faire et ce
qui est incroyable c'est qu'on a réussi
à déterminer le code génétique de
l'intégralité du virus et on a réussi
grâce à la rn justement à partir d'un
brin dahirel pouvoir créer justement
cette protéine est ce celle à spike
c'est la protéine spike donc est ce
qu'on fait on va prendre cet arn la rn
et hyper fragile et si on le met
directement il va être détruit c'est
pour ça qu'on va l'entourer d'une couche
de lipides qu'on appelle des
nanoparticules
c'est pas une puce 5g qu'on vous mais
c'est quelque chose qui permet de planer
au but réussis pour justement éviter que
le virus de la reine se dégrade donc
qu'est-ce qu'on dirait quand on vous
vaccine on va vous mettre la seringue
comme ça est dedans on vous met un peu
d'ail rennes qu'on va mettre dans votre
cellule qui met juste là on vous injecte
là vous avez de la rnt dans la cellule
qui ce qui va se passer
eh bien on va créer à ce moment là cette
petite protéine est ce qui m'arrive est
naturellement elle va sortir de la
cellule et une fois qu'elle va être
sorti de la ceni qu'est ce qui va se
passer votre système immunitaire va se
dire le là on est en train de tomber
malade
elle va donc créer des anticorps fort
naturellement plein d'anticorps vont
être créés juste là le jour elle
rencontre le virus c'est à dire une fois
que vous allez rencontrer quelqu'un qui
est malade ni que ça mais au lieu de
tomber malade
vous avez ces anticorps qui sont juste
là qui vont venir se fixer là et qui
vont empêcher
finalement vous de tomber presque ça
veut dire digérer dernière chose est la
chose la plus importante
on dit souvent que la rn change le code
génétique oui eh bien figurez-vous que
le code génétique l'adn il est là où ça
ici à l'intérieur dans le noyau la rn ne
va jamais dans l'adn jamais votre
matériel génétique ne sera jamais jamais
changé la seule chose qui va se passer
c'est que votre système immunitaire va
créer lui même les anticorps et va vous
savez déjà c'est le finder qui fait ça
c'est le bac
l'un d'eux max en fait c'est exactement
parce que l'autre astrazeneca c'est pas
pareil c'est un peu différent on se
serre mais ça na dé noël russe c'est ce
qu'a démontré rio et sur lequel on met
vient d'ouvrir un peu de particules et
vous allez en quelques centièmes au
système unitaire donc en gros ce qui se
passe avec la vaccination c'est votre
on vous donne un coup de pouce on vous
donne un petit message et c'est la rn
messager qui vous permet de créer la
vaccination raison aussi pour laquelle
les personnes âgées ont un peu moins
d'anticorps parce qu'ils ont un système
immunitaire un peu moins performant et
donc en vieillissant ces anticorps et
bien il y en a un peu moins c'est pour
ça que finalement elles sont moins bien
sage et que les jeunes mais la rn
message et ne changera pas votre code
génétique voilà et vous allez juste est
vacciné protéger de façon naturelle est
alors une personne âgée qui aurait été
vaccinés oui en scène je dit ça comme ça
cathy vingtaine et oriente scène on peut
faire le johnson johnson ou las razones
etc a après 55 ans la seule chose c'est
qu'on sait que l'aide soit pas efficace
mais quel que soit le vaccin et j'ai des
patients que will astrazeneca en
première dose ils ont attrapé le courant
d'un virus parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'une dose n'est pas suffisante et bien
sûr les patients que j'ai eu aucun n'a
fait de forme grave
au lieu d'aller à l'hôpital au lieu d'en
mourir eh bien je donnais un test pcr
positif alors certains ont eu des
températures mais ils n'en sont pas
morts et c'est ça aussi l'enjeu c'est
que la vaccination ça marche ça sauve
des vies on se rend compte qu'en ce
moment
l'épidémie est en train de s'écrouler
partout là on vaccine l'épidémie
d'e.coli et donc c'est une perspective
de retrouver une vie normale
à condition qu'on soit tous vaccinés
pour éviter l'émergence de variants
floreffe lui pour eux c'est pas de moi
elle s'écroule aussi là où on vaccine
beaucoup moins c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure donc il faut à
présent c'est que c'est aussi un td
saisonnalité mais bien sûr c'est
multifactoriel
comment un même bien si vous avez de la
douleur vous avez des pays
vous savez ainsi dix jours jours sur le
portugal vous avez même résultat que
l'on a lui même moment où il ya même
vaccination qu'en france pas mieux c'est
bien dans la religion de svt sciences
nat
vous savez mes parents me verront a fait
des schémas pour essayer de nous
convaincre du confinement ça m'a jamais
convaincu
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que les
essais cliniques pour les enfants ça a
commencé en mars
il ya deux mois de recul c'est pas assez
et que sur la rn messages et les essais
cliniques
ils sont deux faces on est dans une
autorisation de mission de marge
opérationnelle vous on est sur des
essais cliniques qui sont pas et que
c'est trop tôt florian mais bien sûr et
puis surtout pour les enfants encore une
fois n'y a pas d'intérêt donc on les
utilise et un peu comme je le dis du
bouche-trou dubouch piqûre voilà du
bouche à seringue pour pour eux pour les
autres et ça c'est inacceptable du point
de vue éthique morale philosophique
moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup d'eux et de pressions sur la
vaccination
ça m'inquiète énormément
joie alors il s'appelle peter piot c'est
un virologue et lui se prend pas pour un
enfant parce que justement vacciner les
enfants tous les tout le monde c'est le
conseiller spécial de morceaux la fender
daianu sa villa compte la président de
la commission européenne et lui il dit
il résulte d'une formule vaccination ou
interdictions d'entrée
je m'attends à ce qu'il ya des
restrictions pour ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés
c'est le pass sanitaire le pass
vaccinale ça je suis pas d'accord avec
cette société là où il ya plus de secret
médical où on crée des différences d
apartheid entre ceux qui sont restés
toujours avec mais c'est dramatique
c'est une voiture de civilisation dont
on se rend pas compte et derrière dans
ce pass sanitaire dans ce qr codes on
pourra y mettre autre chose demain
ne rentrons pas dans cette société là ni
rentrons surtout pas et encore moins
pour les enfants on voit qu'il n'ya pas
de mort et de former le corps ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs qui vous
plaît faut-il vacciner les enfants merci
oui à 31% non à 72%